tag 7 in putins krieg gegen die ukraine
menschen sterben die angriffe immer
heftiger verletzte werden aus trümmern
geworden
putin kiew mit panzern einkreisen aber
wird nie die herzen des ukrainischen
volkes gewinnen er wird ihre liebe für
die freiheit nie auslöschen und er wird
nie die entschlossenheit der freien welt
schwächen
deutliche worte und heftige kritik an
putin von us präsident joe biden in
seiner rede zur lage der nation herzlich
willkommen auch heute wieder zu einem
zdf spezial
ja es gibt weltweit solidarität mit der
ukraine dort aber geht der krieg
unvermindert weiter die ukraine spricht
mittlerweile von mehr als 2000 getöteten
zivilisten einen überblick über die lage
hat cornelia donath
längst geht es nicht nur um kiew und
kharkiv die russischen angriffe gelten
auch anderen großstädten in sutum
mehrere 140 kilometer westlich der
hauptstadt fürchten 270.000 menschen
letzte nacht um ihr leben vermutlich
marschflugkörper schlagen hier ein
feuerwehrmänner bergen tote retten leben
einer ruft leute hier ist ein mann im
haus hier im haus seid vorsichtig der
bürgermeister richtet sich an seine
einwohner
mehrere bomben sind eingeschlagen
gebäude wurden zerstört
die türen und fenster unseres
krankenhauses rausgerissen wie viele
tote es gibt ist noch unklar
rettungskräfte sind im einsatz die nacht
wird nicht ruhig
als die nacht weicht zeigen sich die
trümmer die menschen hier haben alles
verloren
auch die hauptstadt selbst bank weiter
die straßen fast menschenleer nur vor
supermärkten und tankstellen stehen sie
die langen schlangen bürgermeister
klitschko meldet sich mit lageberichten
der feind rückt mit seinen truppen immer
näher an die hauptstadt heran bila
zerkwa wurde letzte nacht bombardiert
auch im buch ein hostel gehen die kämpfe
weiter wir machen uns bereit und wir
werden unsere stadt verteidigen
barbie am rande der stadt hier
archivbilder die holocaust gedenkstätte
für die dort von den nazis ermordeten
33.000 juden auch getroffen von den
russischen raketen als präsident sie
lenski davon gestern während eines
interviews erfährt bleibt ihm ungläubig
staunend nur sarkasmus
das ist russland meine glückwünsche
dafür später wird er deutlich
das ist unmenschlich
solch ein angriff zeigt dass kiel für
viele russen völlig fremd ist sie wissen
nichts über unsere hauptstadt oder
unsere geschichte aber sie haben den
befehl unsere geschichte auszulöschen
unser land aus zu löschen und uns alle
auszulöschen
im süden geht der dauerbeschuss weiter
in mariupol schaffen es längst nicht
alle verletzten ins krankenhaus viele
können sie nicht mal von den straßen und
aus den häusern holen meldet der
bürgermeister
außerdem sei die wasserversorgung
ausgefallen
und dann wird in diesen wahnsinn hinein
ein leben geboren
ich hatte so angst ein baby in diesen
zeiten zu bekommen ich bin den ärzten so
dankbar die mir bei der geburt geholfen
haben unter diesen umständen
ich glaube daran dass alles gut wird
die stadt sei nach wie vor unter
ukrainische kontrolle das sollen diese
angriffe auf russische truppen zeigen
die bilder kommen vom ukrainischen
innenministerium
was geschieht in der hafenstadt hessen
ist sie von russen umzingelt oder gar
eingenommen wie moskau meldet und diese
bilder zeigen sollen nein die stadt sei
nicht gefallen und verteidige sich heißt
es aus dem umfeld von präsident selensky
nur dass es viele tote gibt ist wohl
sicher
und auch auftrag schon seit tagen im
fokus russische angriffe fliegen weiter
die raketen von der innenstadt bleibt
immer weniger übrig
[Applaus]
das grauen des krieges zeigt sich längst
auch in den wohngebieten wie viele tote
es hier bereits zu beklagen gibt ist
nicht bekannt
mindestens 21 sollen es allein in den
letzten 24 stunden seien heißt es
sechs raketen sind über uns geflogen die
restlichen habe ich nicht gesehen aber
hier hier ist eine eingeschlagen
wir haben schreckliche angst warum wir
hier sind auch ganz normale leute viele
dieser normalen leute wie es für planer
sind längst auf der flucht richtung
westen ein anlaufpunkt muca tivo von
hier ist es nicht mehr weit in die
sicheren nachbarstaaten ein
provisorisches koordinierungszentrum für
flüchtlinge haben sie hier eingerichtet
freiwillige helfen rund um die uhr
versorgen die die aus allen teilen der
ukraine hier ankommen
wir werden sehr von den menschen aus der
gegend unterstützt leute melden sich
fragen was wir brauchen was sie bringen
können
pumpen sind in luca giro noch nicht
gefallen deshalb bleibt immer erst mal
aus kiew ist sie geflohen jetzt will sie
ihren landsleuten helfen
wir helfen den bewohnern ihre keller
sicher zu machen für den fall eines
angriffs seit ich hier bin ist alles gut
so weit aber wer weiß schon was als
nächstes passiert ich weiß es nicht
von luca giro geht es für viele über die
grenze nach ungarn und nach sony zum
beispiel am bahnhof kommen täglich
hunderte an michael und seine freundin
haben es auch geschafft fünf tage war
das paar unterwegs von kiew bis hierher
nach ungarn sie ist ukrainerin er russe
nun sind beide flüchtlinge
ich habe über ein jahr in der ukraine
gelebt dann begann dieser wahnsinn es
ist krank russland wird viele viele
jahre dafür bezahlen müssen und putin
der sollte vor gericht gestellt werden
sie sind erschöpft verzweifelt aber hier
sind sie in sicherheit
am schlimmsten ist es jetzt in kiew und
hackl viele sind schon gestorben jeder
der mich hören kann bitte helft unserem
meinem land und
in wien begrüße ich jetzt den experten
für militärstrategie franz stephan gar
die guten abend gute nacht
wie sehen sie denn die militärische lage
im moment
nun ich glaube man muss festhalten
zuallererst hier dass vieles für die
russischen streitkräfte nicht in die
richtige richtung gegangen ist in den
letzten tagen aber einiges doch sehr gut
geklappt hat wenn man so formulieren
kann ich weiß dass das mediale interesse
zur zeit auf dem norden liegt ab kiew
auf diese berühmt berüchtigte kolonne
die 40 kilometer lang sein soll die
immer fest steht in wirklichkeit aber
glaube ich es operativ von einem
lagebild aus einem militärischen die
situation im süden viel bedenklicher für
die griechischen streitkräfte hier
stoßen die russen weit tief in den raum
auch vormachen erhebliche fortschritte
und das könnte eine große gefahr für die
ukrainische streitkräfte längerfristig
eben darstellen dann blicken wir doch
noch auf die hauptstadt wann glauben sie
denn beginnt der große angriff kehrt
nun ich glaube zuallererst wird einmal
die stadt eingekesselt das heißt es
wären wahrscheinlich kleinere attacken
stattfinden um die
verteidigung stärke der stadt neben zu
testen ich glaube wir werden mit
leichteren angriffen in den nächsten
tagen zu rechnen haben vielleicht
symbolische raketenangriff ich kann mir
vorstellen eine rakete auf den man
einfach um zu signalisieren wir werden
kommen wir
züchten und ihr müsst die stadt lassen
weil ich glaube die russen haben das
interesse das natürlich so viele
bewohner von tieren wie nur möglich die
stadt verlassen es kann nicht im
russischen interesse nehmen die stadt
haus für haus erobern zu müssen bei
russland nicht die kräfte hat für diesen
kampf im urbanen raum hat die
ukrainische medien überhaupt eine chance
gegen diese russische firma
das ist schwierig zu sagen
selbstverständlich und natürlich haben
wir in den letzten tagen relativ wenig
an informationsfluss gehabt was die den
status der griechischen streitkräfte
betrifft letztendlich werden sie nach
und nach ab genutzt egal wie weit sie
sich schlagen zu führen sehr gekonnt
verzögerungs kämpfe entlang der ganzen
fronten aber sie sind nur zahlenmäßig
unterlegen und auch qualitativ sind im
großen und ganzen die streitkräfte nach
wie vor den russischen unterlegen er gar
die vielen dank fürs dahin wir sprechen
gleich nochmal
der kreml hat ja verboten von einem
krieg oder einer invasion nein moment
wir wollten erst mal auf die russischen
truppen schauen der genau da hatte kreml
verboten von einem krieg oder in version
zu sprechen doch es sterben russische
soldaten in der ukraine
erstmals räumt das
verteidigungsministerium jetzt fast 500
tote ein und es gibt gefangene wie die
angehörigen in russland reagieren anne
gellinek
russische militär hubschrauber über der
ukraine material das das moskauer
verteidigungsministerium freigegeben hat
die bilder sollen eine gut vorbereitete
und erfolgreiche militär operation
zeigen soldaten die die ukraine befreien
von einem faschistischen regime so der
auftrag des kreml doch die russischen
militärs werden nicht als befreier
empfangen sondern als besatzer die
operation läuft nicht optimal soldaten
sterben oder werden gefangen genommen
das ukrainische innenministerium hat
eine website auf russisch eingerichtet
die sucht deine leute heißt und videos
von russischen kriegsgefangenen zeigen
soll die ukrainische regierung nutzt die
unter zwang entstanden in interviews mit
zum teil gefesselten soldaten für ihre
eigenen zwecke und führt junge
demoralisierte männer vor was wollen sie
ihren eltern sagen ich liebe euch
wir fahren auf eine übung hieß es jetzt
bin ich hier
wir haben uns richtung kiew bewegt als
wir von der ukrainischen armee aus
granatwerfern beschossen wurden wir
haben zurückgeschossen aber unsere
munition ging zu ende so kam ich in
gefangenschaft
die moskauer staatsanwaltschaft hat die
website sofort blockiert sie passt nicht
ins bild einer gut laufenden
spezialoperation trotzdem verbreiten
sich die nachrichten über russische
kriegsgefangene zu hause wie ein
lauffeuer in moskau hat natalia die
neckar ein foto ihres 19 jährigen sohnes
rafik auf eine ukrainische website
entdeckt offenbar ist er schon am ersten
tag des russischen einmarsches
festgenommen worden
ich fühle mich wie ein stein ich weine
nicht ich schlafe nicht ich es nicht ich
lebe von kaffee und zigaretten weinen
werde ich erst wenn ich meinen sohn
umarmen kann
natalia hat versucht bei offiziellen
stellen auskunft zu bekommen ohne erfolg
ich habe gesagt dass ich die mutter
eines gefangenen soldaten bin und dass
ich kontakt suchen die armee schickt sie
zum roten kreuz das komitee der
soldatenmütter in moskau wird von
anfragen überschwemmt
wir hatten über 2000 anrufe die
meistgestellten fragen sind was ist mit
meinem kind passiert
lebt er noch ist er umgekommen oder in
gefangenschaft wo befindet sich mein
kind
das russische staatsfernsehen berichtet
unterdessen weder über eigene gefangenen
noch über angriffe der russischen armee
auf ukrainische städte der krieg findet
hier nur im donbass stadt in den
separatisten gebieten die von der
ukraine angegriffen würden und auch die
russische seite präsentiert einen
kriegsgefangenen der für ein
ukrainisches bataillon gekämpft haben
soll
sie wurden von litauern ausgebildet
andere abteilungen sind von kann ardian
trainieren wollen
auch diese aussage natürlich nicht
freiwillig sie stützt die kreml
erzählung dass der westen den krieg
verursacht habe das komitee der
soldatenmütter in russland fordert nun
eine sofortige feuerpause damit beide
seiten gefangenen austauschen können bis
jetzt verhalten dieser appell ungehört
zugeschaltet ist weiterhin franz stephan
gar die wie sehen sie denn die situation
der russischen soldaten
ich glaube es ist wichtig zu verstehen
ihr das natürlich beide seiten versuchen
diesen informationskrieg auch
erfolgreich zu gewinnen in dieser
hinsicht hat glaube ich die ukraine die
obere hand aus dem einfachen grund weil
die russen nicht die vorarbeit für einen
informationskrieg geleistet haben vor in
version aus zwecken der geheimhaltung
selbstverständlich und dass er bis alle
informationen bezüglich der niedrigen
man angeblich niedrigen moral der
russischen streitkräfte zum beispiel mit
grosser vorsicht zu geniessen das mag
stimmen es gibt auch evidenz dass einige
einheiten einfach weggelaufen sind bzw
ihre fahrzeuge verlassen haben aber
dadurch entsteht kein großes lagebild um
wirklich zu evaluieren wie stark ihre
kampfmoral russischen streitkräfte ist
wir wissen dass die ukrainische kampf
war auf jeden fall sehr hoch ist was
kann denn ihrer meinung nach putin
überhaupt noch starten
das ist eine gute frage und in der
hinsicht
glaube ich dass das vielleicht zu früh
ist wir sind das dann beginn dieses
feldzugs aber wenn ich das so
formulieren kann meiner meinung nach und
jetzt natürlich diplomatie gefragt auch
auf allen ebenen die trotz dieses
konflikts natürlich gesucht dann muss
wir müssen den kontakt zum krämer auch
suchen der westen
sanktionen allein können hier natürlich
nicht die hand wird bleiben aber
selbstverständlich ist das jetzt in
vieler hinsicht noch wahrscheinlich zu
früh ihr wirklich die diplomatischen
schüler auszustrecken und vielleicht
trotzdem noch ganz kurz was heißt das
ganze für die geo strategie und die
aufstellung der nato
nun ich glaub früher oder später werden
wahrscheinlich darüber sprechen müssen
ob wir eine permanente
truppenpräsenz der nato in
osteuropäischen städten haben werden
beziehungsweise eine aufstockung von
nato-truppen in osteuropa ich glaube das
werden wahrscheinlich die unmittelbare
konsequenz zu sein geopolitisch glaube
ich werden wir einfach unterscheiden in
einer zeit vor dem 24 februar 2022 und
eine zeit nach dem 24 februar 20 22 also
eine wirkliche politische zeitenwende in
meiner meinung nach eine zeitenwende
vielen dank nach wien
und dann wollen wir natürlich auch heute
wieder in die ukraine blicken hier live
bilder aus kiew erscheint im moment
ruhig zu sein am himmel über der
hauptstadt
doch wie erleben die menschen den krieg
wir haben stimmen gesammelt nur ein
ausschnitt von tausenden schicksal
die stets von neuem
fenster
und sophie und nur ein bisschen von
russischen raketen zu schützen
es ist gefährlich hier und vielleicht es
ist nicht die beste entscheidend für
mich persönlich aber ja ich will bleiben
ich das ist meine stadt verstehen sie
und wir alle wollen unsere schützen
ich habe auch wasser fall ist bekannt
keiner im badezimmer haben wir dann also
ich hab mich ein bisschen vorbereitet
ich schlafe am fußboden im flow aber es
ist sowieso besser alles eben der u bahn
nach krieg und begleitet haben und jetzt
schlafpositionen weil
die wende am dicksten sind und falls
deren shrek hätte meine wollen krieg
habe ich die beste chance
[Musik]
wir haben die ukraine verlassen mit dem
ganzen team unserer kirche unser freund
pastor gerhard kotter hilft uns zu
fliehen wir sind auf dem weg nach
deutschland an einem sicheren ort
ich hoffe zwei wochen in odessa ich bin
pastor und bin darauf international mit
den ukrainischen gemeinden sehr
verknüpft und haben gesagt wir müssen
unsere leute rausholen wir haben gehört
aber es geht los haben ständig kontakt
gehabt und das thema losgefahren im team
36 leute
meine familie ist aus verschiedenen
gründen in odessa geblieben die gute
nachricht ist dass sie alle am leben
seien die schlechte ist dass sich das
jederzeit ändern
in den läden gibt es nicht mehr alles es
bilden sich lange schlangen benzin kann
man nur noch in kleinen mengen kaufen
manchmal haben wir keinen strom aber in
anderen städten dass die situation viel
viel schlimmer
du weißt einfach nicht was als nächstes
passieren wird werden wir überleben wo
sollen wir hin ist es besser in den
kellern unterschlupf zu finden oder
sollen wir besser raus ins freie
man ist völlig durcheinander
ich kann ihnen nicht alles zeigen denn
ich bin ein offizier bei der fernmelde
truppe das ist der grund
[Musik]
und nun sind wir im hauptquartier in
mikro und wir verteidigen unser
territorium
und ich habe einen doktor in statistik
ich habe 30 jahre meines berufslebens
als umweltingenieur verbracht ich war
ein sehr großer pazifist ich hätte nie
gedacht dass ich mal pistolen und
maschinengewehren in meinen händen
halten würde
aber jetzt glaube ich absolut dass diese
leute in russland die führungskräfte
dieses landes ihr präsident und die
regierung und armee diese leute sollen
zerstört werden
und hier und da sind die sachen für den
fall dass jedoch ganz schnell auf die
straße müssen
manche kinder sind total gestresst
die weinen und haben angst obwohl wir
wie gesagt in odessa frieden in der
stadt haben aber die sind genervt weil
sie nachts in den kellern schlafen wo es
kalt ist und wohl nicht immer die
beleuchtung da ist viele kinder sind
krank geworden weil die keller natürlich
nicht auf diese art der unterbringung
vorbereitet waren wir versuchen unsere
tochter mit allen möglichen mieten zu
lenken natürlich fand sie in dieser
woche auch gelernt was der krieg
bedeutet wenn explosionen kommen jetzt
hat sie gelernt wenn die sirene kommt
oder auch sandy alarmsignal da sie in
den fluren muss dass sie sich verstecken
muss dass wir abends bei den fassade
fenster kein licht anmachen
ich fühle mich halt jeder der seine
familie zurück lässt die eltern
großeltern meine 84 jährige großmutter
mutter vater mein zuhause mein ganzes
leben
wir brauchen jetzt diese große
unterstützung um die russische
wirtschaft zu stoppen und um ihre
regierung zu stoppen
alle sehr stolz auf unseren mut auf
unsere verteidiger auf unseren
präsidenten der gerade in dieser zeit
mit mit uns allen bleibt der alle zwei
bis drei stunden ganz ehrlich uns an
erzählt was gerade passiert
wir haben frau erfahrung frauen die
schießen können ich will nicht eine
granate sein verstehen sie ich will nur
durchhalten ist also wenn ich nicht viel
tun kann dann besser bleibe ich zu hause
mindestens alle journalisten kann ich
den welt informieren was ist nur wenige
was ich tun kann
im kia spreche ich jetzt wird dem
kriegsfotografen sebastian mack aus
guten abend
werden während des gesprächs fotos von
ihnen zeigen doch zunächst mal wie geht
es ihnen
ich bin sehr müde
mir ist aber soweit gut ich bin im
zentrum von kiew in einem hotel
und habe hier auch anschluss an einen
schuss keller für den fall dass damit
ist das das bombardement der russen hier
beginnen sollte habe ich auch die
möglichkeit in das untergeschoss zu
kommen die wir erleben sie die
hauptstadt in diesem moment
heute war ein tag der relativ ruhig der
relativ ruhig war wir haben im
stadtzentrum weniger detonation gehabt
ich konnte mich heute trotz mehrerer
bombenalarme frei bewegen
überall ist eine große geschäftigkeit
von menschen die sowohl zivile als auch
soldaten die schätzen gräben ausheben
straßenblockaden errichteten sandsäcke
ausschütten und das erwarten die
menschen denn für die kommenden tage
wenn man als journalist als fotograf die
menschen direkt fragt sagen sie wir
werden die russen hier vor den
stadtgrenzen wieder vertreiben wenn man
sich aber die sehen auf den straßen
anschaut das
herstellen kann
straßenblockaden und schützengräben dann
ist das natürlich ein anderes signal sie
sind ja professioneller fotograf welche
bilder prägen sich denn ein von diesem
krieg
was mich bisher am meisten beschäftigt
hat emotional für mich ganz persönlich
waren gestern gesehen am hauptbahnhof
verkehrt
menschen die voller panik familien
in totaler panik die versucht haben in
die komplett überfüllten evakuierungs
züge die stadt zu verlassen richtung
westen das militär hat versucht die
menschen dass sie da raus zu schmeißen
mit gewalt die alleine und männlich
unterwegs waren tumultartige szenen
kinder sind aus den zügen gefallen
menschen haben geschrien totale
verzweiflung das ist etwas das nicht
sehr sehr berührt hat und auch noch
länger dauern wird das kann ich mir
vorstellen vielen dank sebastian
backhaus für diese eindrücke und alles
gute nach kiew dankeschön
das gespräch haben wir kurz vor der
sendung aus sicherheitsgründen
aufgezeichnet mehr als
830.000 menschen sind mittlerweile aus
der ukraine geflohen die meisten davon
nach polen seit beginn des russischen
angriffs ist für uns natalie steger an
der polnisch ukrainischen grenze die
hilfsbereitschaft ist groß aber auch die
verzweiflung viele die ihre angehörigen
im krieg zurücklassen mussten
kiew ist 600 kilometer entfernt und doch
sind sie mittendrin lena und ihre
schwiegertochter sind nach polen
geflohen jede minute online jede minute
neuer katastrophen
vor 20 minuten da war eine explosion in
kiew und zivilisten sind tut
wenn ich meinen sohn oder meinen mann
anrufen während ich mit ihnen rede sehe
ich die explosionen und
ich höre
ihre männer versichern ihnen dass sie
nicht kämpfen um sie zu beruhigen
erzählt lena doch sie wissen dass sie es
tun sie und die drei kinder haben
unterschlupf gefunden bei einem
polnischen paar maria und peter die
beiden fahren seit tagen zum
grenzbahnhof holen mütter mit kindern zu
sich nach hause
eine ukrainische mutter mit kind nehmen
sie auch vermittelt von freiwilligen
helfern die frau ist müde erschöpft
verstört will schnell weg endlich soll
der lange fluchtweg vorläufig zu ende
gehen die hilfsbereitschaft ist immens
in polen die ukraine sagen uns alle das
sind unsere nachbarn ist doch
selbstverständlich
es ist sehr traurig was passiert ich
hoffe irgendjemand stoppt diesen
wahnsinnigen putin
amerika ganz europa ist dagegen
hat uns vereint in der angst das ist
doch auch um uns bald treffen könnte und
wir müssten nach sammlungen
die grenzübergänge zu polen zu
zehntausenden fielen die menschen aus
der ukraine seit donnerstag so viele
schicksale seit putin irland in den
krieg getrieben hat alexandra berthold
und ihr mann holen angehört haben die
kinder und den tochter sei traurig weil
es die weibchen war wirklich schwer
wichtig dass die kleine kinder im
sicherheit bleiben mindestens es kann
man nicht erzählen zwar durch den
bändern laufen
der grenzbahnhof im polnischen chemische
noch kommen die züge an aus kiew odessa
länder polen was ich ansonsten abriegelt
gegen flüchtlinge zeigt sich bei den
ukraine ein ganz anders man hat sich
vorbereitet auf die flüchtlingswelle die
nachbarn sind willkommen mensch plus
explizit ihrer haustiere muss es
chemische ihre erste station in den free
was hilft die stadt haben sie fast
komplett dem erdboden gleichgemacht wir
saßen fünf tage im keller und jetzt sind
wir hier haben nur ein paar sachen
mitgenommen wir haben den vater da
gelassen um unseren land zu verteidigen
ich hatte große angst vor den
explosionen weil alles so nah war in der
nähe explodierte
flüchtlinge mitten in europa russland
das ewige schreckgespenst der
osteuropäer
die ausführliche reportage von natalie
steger sehen sie später nahm
auslandsjournal spezial und 22 uhr 15
wie eine weitere eskalation in der
ukraine verhindern mit gezielten
sanktionen versucht es der westen gegen
banken unternehmen und vereinen
privatpersonen aus putins engsten zirkel
besonders viel russisches geld liegt in
london weshalb die stadt auch london
grad genannt wird jetzt machen die
briten ernst und die russischen
oligarchen werden nervös den herlein
stehende ovationen ganz ähnlich wie
jüngst für den ukrainischen präsidenten
im europaparlament gab es heute im
britischen parlament für den
ukrainischen botschafter in london das
beste was man über klatschen hinaus für
den tun könnte wäre die schafe
durchsetzung von sanktionen vor allem
gegen russische oligarchen die
opposition bezweifelt dass dies
geschieht und führt das beispiel des
ehemaligen stellvertretenden
premierministers russlands igor
schuwalow van der ganz um die ecke vom
parlament zwei wohnungen im wert von
über 13 millionen euro besitzt
befindet sich auf der eu sanktionsliste
nicht aber auf unsere wann gedenkt der
premierminister das in ordnung zu
bringen
boris johnson wies den vorwurf zurück
wir sollten stolz auf das sein was wir
bereits getan haben
tatsächlich sind einige dem kreml nahe
stehen der oligarchen inzwischen mit dem
einfrieren von vermögenswerten und
reisebeschränkungen belegt worden
darunter zwei bankenchefs zwar im
gasgeschäft tätige milliardäre ein
ehemaliger schwiegersohn putins und der
boss eines luftfahrtunternehmens
bemerkenswert aber ist wer nicht
abgestraft wurde beispielsweise roman
abramowitsch der besitzer des londoner
premier league vereins fc chelsea
gerüchte dass er den klub nun verkaufen
will erscheinen ebenso nebulös wie
mutmaßung er könnte im ukraine konflikt
vermitteln
ebenfalls bisher davon gekommen ist er
investmentbanker michael friedmann
geschätztes vermögen 13,2 milliarden
euro auch er steht bei der eu auf der
sanktionsliste nicht aber in
großbritannien jetzt ist friedman einer
der ganz wenigen oligarchen die sich
gegen die invasion der ukraine
aussprechen er kann diesen konflikt
nicht lösen uns hier mit sanktionen zu
belegen schafft ungeheuren druck auf uns
persönlich wir haben jedoch keinerlei
einfluss auf politische entscheidungen
in russland
das allerdings wird vom westen
bezweifelt die hoffnung ist dass die
russischen oligarchen ihre hände nicht
länger in unschuld waschen wenn der
druck auf sie weiter erhöht wird
ja und gerade eben kam die nachricht
dass roman abramowitsch sein fußball
klub den fc chelsea verkaufen und mit
dem erlös die opfer des russischen
krieges in der ukraine unterstützen will
dann sprechen wir mit unserem
korrespondenten in moskau christian
selben guten abend schön
was bedeuten die sanktionen denn für die
oligarchen in russland
ja die sanktionen treffen die oligarchen
natürlich massiv in ihren geschäften und
in den letzten tagen ist schon etwas
passiert was man ja sehr selten hört in
russland und sieht öffentliche kritik
die kamen von den oligarchen es gab auch
einen öffentlichen brief putin massiv
kritisiert wurde und dann jetzt ganz
aktuell eben roman abramowitsch
der ankündigt den fc chelsea zu
verkaufen von vier milliarden euro ist
da die rede und er will das geld in die
ukraine geben und den kriegsopfern
zugute kommen lassen das ist natürlich
ein klares signal an die ukraine aber es
ist auch ein sehr klares signal an
wladimir putin heute gab es ja auch
berichte über friedensgespräche was ist
da der stand
ja die friedensgespräche die sind heute
nicht zustande gekommen russland hatte
angekündigt eine delegation zu schicken
die delegation war dann auch am
verhandlungsort dann war es den ganzen
tag nicht klar ob eine delegation aus
kiew jetzt auch dazu kommt die soll auf
dem weg sein aber die gespräche werden
heute nicht mehr stattfinden die rede
ist dann von morgen aber die
erwartungshaltung insgesamt an diese
gespräche ist eben wegen der
maximalforderung russlands und der
position kiews ist von den gesprächen
nicht so viel zu erwarten was bekommt
bei den im moment von vladimir putin mit
vladimir putin macht sich rar aber ich
finde das darf man nicht
fehlinterpretieren wir erleben dass seit
beginn der pandemie dass er sich eher
zurück zieht das er fiel aus einem büro
arbeitet in video schalten ist sich dort
trifft mit ministern und auch
internationale gespräche führt
er hat wohl große sorge sich mit kuwait
anzustecken hält der abstand auch zu den
staats und regierungschefs die jetzt
kürzlich noch in moskau waren als er ist
im moment auch eher zurückgezogen hatte
heute auch nur einen öffentlichen termin
mit der union der geschäftsleute hier in
moskau zimmern das wurde behauptet dass
es heute gewesen ist er tritt nicht
öffentlich auf aber daraus kann man
jetzt nicht um den grip rückschlüsse auf
die aktuelle situation ziehen vielen
dank christian seien nach moskau
ja sicher geglaubte gewissheiten hat
dieser krieg zunichte gemacht viele auch
in deutschland wollen nicht tatenlos
zusehen um ein leskovar über hilfe und
solidarität
berlin hauptbahnhof am nachmittag wieder
erreichen züge mit geflüchteten aus der
ukraine die hauptstadt nachdem es
gestern abend sehr viele waren verlief
der heutige tag des lang ruhen wer es
bis hierher geschafft hat ist oft
entkräftet war mehrere tage lang
unterwegs steht immer noch unter dem
eindruck des geschehens
es war eine sehr schwere entscheidung zu
gehen weil meine mutter alt ist aber
mein sohn hat uns geraten dass wir gehen
sollen um unser leben zu retten
es war wirklich sehr hart wir waren drei
tage lang unterwegs bekommen auch so
dass zum glück haben uns viele menschen
geholfen wir sind ihnen sehr dankbar
geholfen wird den geflüchteten auch am
bahnhof von immer mehr freiwilligen es
geht direkt nach der ankunft
kleiderspenden für kleinkinder das
nötigste viele der helfer haben
verwandte oder kommen selbst aus
russland oder den nachbarstaaten so auch
angelina müller auch sie teilt essen aus
übersetzt für die neuankömmlinge eine
selbstverständlichkeit für die studenten
nicht die machen kann weiß der student
und bin ich viel geld habe aber das
mindeste was ich tun kann es hier zu
sein zu helfen angebote zum übernachten
bieten mittlerweile nicht nur normale
wohnungsmieter hier in berlin kreuzberg
können geflüchtete in appartements
einchecken unentgeltlich am wochenende
kam florian richtet man die idee die er
dann im internet breit gestreute
und da hatte das verselbstständigt habe
ich einige organisationen angerufen
gefragt wie viele machen können und
keine ahnung wir sind jetzt heute erst
mal 20 25 appartements und dann gucken
wir mal was dann auch alles geht trotz
des großen engagements heute wurden
geflüchtete von berlins ankunft zentrum
erstmals nach brandenburg gebracht per
bus die berliner politik hofft auf eine
bessere verteilung fordert eine
schnellere klärung des aufenthaltsstatus
für die ukraine
berlin ist natürlich der große dreh und
angelpunkt auch zielort für viele
menschen die hierher kommen die bis nach
deutschland kommen die kommen zunächst
mal nach berlin wir können einen teil
davon abfangen aber wir brauchen auch
unterstützung der anderen bundesländer
dabei und ja noch morgen werden wieder
geflüchtete von der polnisch
ukrainischen grenze in berlin erwartet
wie viele es sein werden weiß niemand
in münchen auf einer friedens thema ist
für uns stefan leifert
wie groß ist denn der protest geworden
ja die hier in münchen auf dem
königsplatz geht gerade einen abend zu
ende wenn die stadt wohl ziemlich lange
nicht erlebt hat 5000 teilnehmer waren
angemeldet von den organisatoren dieser
demo am ende sind dann weit über 40.000
gekommen während der ganzen
veranstaltung strömten immer neue
menschen hier auf den königsplatz der am
ende aus allen nähten platzte so bunt
wie das veranstalter bündnis so bunt war
auch hier die die zahl der teilnehmer
aufgerufen zu dieser demo haben bis auf
die afg alle politischen parteien
umweltverbände religionsgemeinschaften
sozialverbände waren darunter der wohl
emotionalste moment war die rede von
charlotte knobloch der präsidentin der
israelitischen kultusgemeinde
sie hat das narrativ putins gegeißelt er
immer wieder von der entnazifizierung
der ukraine sprach das war ein sehr
emotionaler und mit langen beifall
bedachter moment oder auch die rede des
us generalkonsuls hiervon münchen der
seine rede mit dem ausruf beendete heute
sind wir alle ukraine auch da gab es
langanhaltenden beifall münchen hat ein
sehr enges verhältnis zu ukraine wie
bayern überhaupt durch drei große
städtepartnerschaften münchen ist
hat eine städtepartnerschaft mit kiew
regensburg mit odessa oder nürnberg mit
harke von diese nähe zur ukraine
die spiegelt sich im moment auch wieder
in der hilfsbereitschaft der bayern
überall sind die spenden anlaufpunkte
sehr sehr voll haben großen zulauf und
auch die bereitschaft zur aufnahme von
flüchtlingen hier in bayern ist ziemlich
groß und heute abend hat münchen diese
solidarität mit einer sehr
eindrucksvollen demo jetzt in diesen
minuten zu ende geht untermauert vielen
dank stefan leifert und größe nach
münchen
wenn sie den menschen in der ukraine
helfen wollen können sie das tue und
beim aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine ebay.de
65 104 106 100 104 106 100 alle infos
auch unter spenden zdf de oder im zdf
text auf seite 8 190
tja und im westen der ukraine ukraine
rund 280 kilometer luftlinie entfernt
von der hauptstadt kiew ist katrin
eigendorf für uns
kathrin wie ist ihre einschätzung der
lage im moment
ja wie man es vielleicht leise im
hintergrund gehört haben wir auch gerade
wieder fliegeralarm das geht den ganzen
tag schon so auch hier wird die lage
immer brenzliger auch hier rechnet man
inzwischen damit dass die stadt aus der
luft angegriffen werden kann hier wurde
auch heute schon ein russischer
kampfflieger über der stadt gesichtet
120 kilometer entfernt von hier wurde
eine munitionsfabrik
bombardiert aber dennoch man sich die
lage im gesamten land anguckt dann
konzentrieren sich nicht natürlich die
angriffe vor allem auf den osten vor
allem auf die stadt charkiw und auf die
stadt kiew was wir von da hören sind
wirklich ganz dramatische meldungen die
natürlich die menschen auch hier in
große unruhe versetzen nicht einmal ein
beispiel wir haben gerade die meldung
von dem direktor einer
eines blinden heims bekommen in dem
blinde kinder leben das bombardiert
wurde und jetzt komplett von der
versorgung abgeschnitten ist und der
wirklich sich mit einem hilferuf im netz
da ran an die menschen wendet was kann
ich tun sollen die kinder hier jetzt
verhungern ich weiß gar nicht wir haben
auch keine heizung mehr
diese meldungen sorgen hier für große
unruhe obwohl die solidarität wirklich
sehr sehr groß nach wie vor ist wächst
eben auch das schwer schmerzliche
wahrnehmen des dessen was hier mit der
bevölkerung passiert und viele menschen
erleben wir eben auch hier die weinen
was erwarten sie denn für die kommenden
stunden die kommenden tage und
die friedensverhandlungen
sind ja zum nächst heute gescheitert
beziehungsweise nicht zustande gekommen
es ist eine option dass die gespräche
weitergeführt werden aber beide seiten
sind ja sehr sehr weit voneinander
entfernt die ukraine erwarten hier dass
der krieg ich unverminderter härte
weiter geht was ich erwarte ist dass die
ukrainische bevölkerung weiter
erbitterten widerstand leisten wird also
das ist auch alles was wir von unseren
gesprächspartnern hier hören die leute
sagen wir werden hier nicht weichen wir
bereiten uns darauf vor unser land zu
verteidigen also diese haltung ist
ungebrochen
was ich ganz interessant finde viele
menschen versuchen jetzt mit bussen ins
gespräch zu kommen ich habe zum beispiel
heute mit einem buchhändler gesprochen
er sagt ich habe familie in russland ich
rufe die immer wieder an und erzähle
denen was hier passiert man versucht
auch russische soldaten die hier
gefangen genommen wurden dazu zu bewegen
zu hause anzurufen ihren müttern zu
erzählen was hier passiert also einfach
auch auf die russische bevölkerung
einzuwirken und klar zu machen
dass hier eben putin nicht die
interessen russlands verteidigt sondern
versucht ein volk zu vernichten was
viele russen ja auch als als bruder
erfolg betrachten wenn
katrin eigendorf und alles gute in der
ukraine
die reaktion der unabhängigen russischen
tageszeitung nowaja gaseta auf die
drohung der behörden unabhängige medien
zu sperren wenn sie veröffentlichungen
über den krieg in der ukraine nicht
löschen war übrigens es gibt noch eine
gute nachricht das wort frieden wurde
noch nicht verboten
mehr informationen später im
heute-journal und danach in einem
auslandsjournal spezial putins krieg bis
dahin auch wieder sehr
[Musik]
unruhe an der heimatfront wie reagieren
die russen auf putins angriffskrieg
und direkt danach putin der enthemmte
disput vom unsichtbaren kgb-agenten zum
gefürchteten herrscher sein